i wish there was still this enthusiasm i
have two
daughters who are 18 and 20 and this is
the first presidential election they get
to vote in
and um joe biden was pretty much
the least liked candidate among young
people for
all the candidates yeah so young people
are having to learn
how old are you man i'm 33 so
i'm 40 and the older you get sometimes
you vote for people you just half like
and that's how politics can be you don't
always get to vote for somebody that
just
blows you away right you don't even
always get to vote for people you love
sometimes you have to be super practical
about it and say
this guy donald trump is a monster
and he has to be defeated and even
though i'm not enthusiastic about joe
biden and have all of these criticisms
for me this year i'm really voting to
defeat donald trump
yeah i do think that that is kind of the
weird uh
because i've been super critical of joe
biden on on social media especially
during the primaries um
and i feel like that is the position
that people like you and i are in that
have
platforms that people for whatever
reason obviously yours is a lot bigger
than mine but people like look
look to us for whatever reason it's kind
of a weird you know
situation to be in because it's like hey
you know had maybe this not been donald
trump that
joe biden was running against like maybe
you might ride in a
a third party candidate or something but
now is the time
no i don't yeah i agree or guess what
another four years of trump
might just there the world might be gone
as we know it you know what i'm saying
here's the thing man you and i have
a certain level of success and
privilege and security but donald trump
is a dire threat to very particular
communities in this country
and we owe it we owe it to
immigrants in this country we owe it to
muslims in this country and to many
other communities
to make sure that he doesn't have
another day in office
he um even his
gross mismanagement of particularly his
gross mismanagement of the of the
pandemic
i think will go down in presidential
history as one of the greatest failures
in american leadership yeah man it's not
the greatest it's one of them
well here's the thing you know we are
celebrating
now in other countries that have gone a
hundred days
without a single case and our country
just crossed five million
i saw you post you know the rankings of
all the countries and it's
it's crazy when you look at the
countries
that are getting that are growing in the
pandemic
it is it's all developing countries
and the united states and now we don't
like to think of ourselves as a
developing nation
but we have to ask ourselves why are we
not only on this list
but we're leading the list and i just
think the united states
it's even it even gets to our health
care systems it gets into
racism and discrimination and how
inequity is built into our nation
there's a reason why we're failing
and almost every other developed nation
in the world has already flattened the
curve they're already past it
and uh there's almost no i don't see any
end in sight for us right now